[Music]
hey you guys happy sunday
i don't actually know how many people
are in there nobody's talking there's
people in there okay
oh okay my maybe my chat is not because
i don't have any anybody here remember
my channel
yeah i don't know why oh there we go
there's there's
it was just kind of like on the wrong
setting no it was on the right setting
it just didn't refresh it yeah it just
maybe did a brain fart or a chat fart if
you want to call it that
okay the last duel
yeah we had mentioned this i think on
one of our older shows and a couple of
you said that it was really good and uh
so dermot one of our uh patrons and
listeners yeah he's regular all he sent
us yeah sent us um an amazon gift card
to buy it so i did yeah got it on
blu-ray we had wanted to see this on in
the theater but for whatever reason we
just didn't get around to it i feel like
well no because it played we saw other
movies around this time like halloween
kills came out around the same time and
last night in soho and stuff like that
yeah so i remember going to see a bunch
of movies right around the time this
came out but we just didn't get around
to seeing it and then like it really
tanked at the box office and then i kept
seeing reviews saying oh this shouldn't
have tagged because it's really good and
so finally we got around to watching it
and it actually is quite good yeah it's
good i would probably put this there
with the northmen it's just the norsemen
it's just a different
it's a different story it's not as
hardcore you know it's not ruthless but
this is like
it it's
it's taking place
kind of in a more civilized time it's
still medieval you know between some
knights and some lords or ways that's a
squire and i guess the other guy is a a
duke
he said the king's son
or the king's uh
he's the king's uh cousin isn't he
well the count is he's
better he's an account yeah the ban
after that guy okay i didn't know if he
was a duke or whatever he was account
yeah because i don't think they ever
call him by his title if they did i
didn't i didn't realize that they were
using it they just called pierre mostly
but yeah yeah
it's taking place in a more organized
civilized time than the norseman but
it's just as accurate this is actually
something based on a historical event
that actually happened that is actually
quite well documented for something
happened that happened and i think it
happened in like 1380 or something like
that
yeah dude rape's a night's wife
and the guy's
linked up with this count
he's lower rank than him he's only a
squire
but he's got a lot of political pull
and uh they could have let it go but
um no he wanted [ __ ] he wanted
justice
he couldn't get justice in the court so
he had to go to the church and the
church gave him [ __ ] trial by ordeal
or trial by duel which i believe in all
this [ __ ] i believe in dueling tribe i
do all that [ __ ] okay
uh i don't necessarily mean it's based
in reality it's just another it's
another system it's cultural to us you
know
[ __ ] if i was guilty that's what i
would want i don't want to do trial by
ordeal or something you know
anyway
it goes to this uh [ __ ] duel and i
didn't know who was going to win so i
don't want to spoil it yeah we're not
going to i mean well i mean this is
based on a real thing yeah but i didn't
look it up did you no not before not
before i watched it right don't look it
up if you if you don't know the answer
yeah because knowing was a lot better
and then once i find out who won i was
like okay
um
but it's a pretty good character story
and it felt real um authentic in terms
of the way people were the way they
acted and a lot of [ __ ] went down
a lot of people were the kind of the way
i i i suspected them of being back in
in those days just based on things that
i had read and picked up and things that
you can kind of read between the lines
and you go you know i bet those
[ __ ] partied a lot they did
um the cat was
he's a bad dude man i mean he was not
really a bad dude he was a smart guy
he was worldly but he didn't believe any
of that medieval [ __ ] he knew it was
just a false system that they were born
with he didn't really believe in much of
it he was real educated but he just
spent all his time partying and screwing
[ __ ] party girls he'd had like four
or five of them in the bed they're all
[ __ ]
doing each other and he's asking come on
let's get him you know that kind of [ __ ]
they were just looking
him and they were just
taking advantage you know
when everybody else was following or at
least
a lot of the other people were following
the rules of the society
well that's what was interesting about
this movie i mean ben affleck's
character he's not like the main
character he's kind of like he's not one
of the like main three characters he's
kind of like a side character he him and
matt damon uh along with um nicole
hollis cena holla singer i think is how
you pronounce their last name uh they're
the ones that wrote the screenplay
and i think they each wrote their one
because this is kind of like and pretty
much every review you'll see of this has
compared it to uh rasha mom because this
is basically uh it's the same series of
events but told from three different
the different perspectives of the three
different characters yeah everybody
everybody's kind of testimonies tinged
with self-interest you're not really
sure
you pretty much i think the woman's
testimony was the most accurate well she
certainly had the most to lose she had
the most to lose yes um so there really
wasn't any reason for her to lie and to
be honest there was more reason for her
to like keep her [ __ ] mouth shut but
she didn't want to
uh you know she had some balls i gotta
say but it's just it's really
interesting because like i said i don't
want to go into like the end or anything
like that this is based on a book like a
non-fiction book obviously that came
back came out back in 2004
uh which was called the last duel a true
story of trial by combat in medieval
france and like i said i think among at
least people that are you know real uh
you know savvy or know a lot about
medieval history um this is a pretty
famous because this was actually the
last duel in france um and so it's kind
of like famous and well-known and like i
said it's strange because
for something that happened in the 14th
century
there are tons and tons and tons
particularly of the duel itself of
first-hand witness accounts like people
that were there and saw the whole thing
happen
so they kind of like know a lot of what
happened the stuff leading up to it is
you know less documented but it's still
pretty documented um the guy that wrote
the book apparently he went really into
like looking at like property records
and tax records and [ __ ] like that and
even though
the reason for the duel
is the rape of the wife
it's not the thing that kicked off the
two guys rivalry i guess it was just
kind of like the the the cherry on the
[ __ ] sunday if you wanted to say it was
kind of common you could tell something
bad was going to happen
yeah because there was like a they well
they started out as friends yeah right
they were both squires
and they were kind of like they started
out
the only criticism i would give to this
movie is that if you're not familiar
with
like what war this is um i think it's
one of the it's during the hundred years
war is it not yeah i think so
or something like that
but um
so if you're not real familiar with that
like the first
15-20 minutes kind of like jumps around
a lot like it jumps ahead like in time
and stuff they were in brittany weren't
they
yeah see i don't even remember i mean
it's not super important but it's france
it is yeah that's the fruit but it does
say
it does take a little while to like get
invested in the characters just because
they're i mean the movie is kind of long
i mean i didn't think it was too long
but it's like two and a half hours or
whatever it is it kept my attention yeah
it didn't seem like that long to me it's
not slow or anything but um
but they i feel like ridley scott was
trying to like fill in a bunch of like
background material like real quick yeah
it's really scott by the way at the yeah
at the beginning so like the first 15 20
minutes like i said there'll be like a
scene of like a battle or something
that'll jump ahead like six years and
then there's like some other [ __ ] going
on so it takes a a a few minutes to like
get your bearings but once it starts
getting into because matt damon's
character whose name is uh
de carrouge yeah um
he it's his perspective like starts out
so you see everything from his point of
view like why adam driver's character
his name is jacques lagree
how they started out as friends they
were in all these battles together when
they saved each other's lives blah blah
blah and then this whole thing happened
where
that land well matt yeah matt damon felt
like um he was getting like shafted
which i guess he was in a way he was he
was getting shafted he was doing all
that fighting and not getting very much
reward for it and he was kind of getting
like dissed yeah and a lot of that was
because jacqueline adam driver's
character was friends with with the
count played by ben affleck so who was
the you know who was the king's cousin
so he got a lot more favors plus he was
a lot more even though he was also a
[ __ ] because like both of the guys in
this are kind of like both kind of shits
but um
but adam driver's character was more
kind of like a rakish party boy so he
was a lot better at like schmoozing and
being uh you know being like more social
butterflies so people liked him more
because he was charming even though he
was a [ __ ] but
like a slaughter or whatever
what the story is about is you got a
dude he's be he's basically basic [ __ ]
he's a basic [ __ ] really yeah he's
that's uh john he's
he believes in all this stuff he's
religious um he believes in the order he
believes in the government and believes
in every
everything he and he thinks it's all
honest
okay
he's kind of reading into the situation
though you know i mean he he's kind of
in some ways
projecting his honesty and belief in the
system into other people
he's going out actually fighting
and losing friends in [ __ ] wars and
battles
and when he gets back home they kind of
diss him for losing
even though he didn't really it wasn't
his fault he lost yeah and you know he
was fighting all that he was he was
[ __ ] fighting wars and he wasn't
getting much reward for it and during
this while he's going out fighting wars
uh jock or jacques he was the adam
drivers character and the count are
partying up
and just having orgies with all the
[ __ ] girls and stealing land from
people and they're living the [ __ ]
life you know and they're
and the difference between them is that
john is just basic [ __ ] all right well
he's a little humorless yeah he doesn't
have communication he does get [ __ ]
over like you know a land that was
promised to him like when he married
this woman like it was part of her dowry
and like the king sold it off to
somebody else and like so [ __ ] happens
to him where he does get [ __ ] over but
the way that he
goes about writing that is probably not
the best most diplomatic way yeah he
doesn't have any verbal or social skills
really he's real basic
and he doesn't have any political
finesse so he can't really represent
himself
in the social arena of the courts
when he goes there he just tries to hey
i'm working and you're not working well
that's not how you approach it he didn't
know how to approach
yeah
okay
he couldn't schmooze
he couldn't uh he couldn't
use a [ __ ] um
would be a what do you call it
he he couldn't use style intact well he
wasn't seeing that much social growth he
a lot of times he was in the right he's
in the right but he was he didn't know
he was too blunt he was stepping on his
own dick yeah he couldn't represent
himself he couldn't talk to the [ __ ]
uh to the educated class even though
they were basically the same class it's
just that the adam driver character you
know jacques and and the count they
could read and write latin and they
could read all these books and entertain
the girls and the dudes and have these
[ __ ] fantastic parties and then work
jai chi or work work things behind the
scenes to get things done and this other
guy he's like kind of like a basic
soldier all right
um he did get knighted
and yeah
later on he's no he knows he's getting
[ __ ] over they're not calling him sir
yeah and every time
so he's getting more and more pissed
that they're not calling him sir by his
rank which he felt that he heard well he
did earn it yeah all right and
the dude that's really getting
underneath the skin is his ex buddy
who's still a squire who hasn't been
knighted yeah yeah so that was a big
[ __ ] show big throw down over this
[ __ ] and then it turns out later his
wife [ __ ] says that man raped me yeah
and he [ __ ] blows his stack and he
and he doesn't he's are you telling me
the truth you know he's nearly beaten
her ass are you telling me the truth
because she's he doesn't she doesn't
really
see it from his point of view
he now has to go to war for
well he didn't have to that was one of
the things he had to well no but i mean
what i was gonna say was that
he didn't actually have to do the duel
no um but the thing about it was that
the way that it worked out because he
had kind of like burned a lot of his
bridges and because he just went around
constantly aggrieved and constantly
suing people like i said even though
technically he was in the right
the fact that he was just constantly
complaining and interrupting people's
parties and being like hey i'm suing the
count again
and [ __ ] like that so he really kind of
like burned his bridges so then
when it came up that his wife had been
raped by jacques lagree
um
he felt like he didn't have any recourse
because he said well if i take it to the
king or if i take it they'll probably
like [ __ ] me over
because they controlled the courts right
so he was just kind of like well that's
the only thing that i can do now what he
didn't tell his wife until later
was that the the upshot of him having to
do the duel was that if he lost the duel
she would also be burned alive because
if it's evidence yeah because
because they're basically they're saying
well it's a duel so if god lets you win
then that means you're telling the truth
but if you lose that means god says
you're lying and that means your wife is
lying and we will also burn her alive
other than you being i'm gonna go ahead
and reinstate what i said he had to to
go to war with it there was no other way
um and it's because it was an
honor-based society
to go to the courts and be defeated was
to would to be humiliated
a third time so he had to do the duel
because he was religious he believed he
couldn't lose
yeah he told her that he says if i lose
they they're going to kill you for false
testimony against him he goes but it's
not possible for me to lose because
we're innocent he [ __ ] meant that
yeah he believed in trial by ordeal he
didn't think he could lose
but another thing that's really
interesting about this because like i
said what they do is the first chapter
is from matt damon's point of view i'm
jesus yeah you know what i mean
john
the first one's from his point of view
then it's from adam driver's point of
view which is actually funny because
um
he he obviously like sees himself as
like the studly master of all like women
everywhere which is probably like where
some of the problem came about uh and
then you have the third part which is
actually from her point of view and the
interesting thing about it is that
i kind of feel like like i said i think
what she described is probably way
closer to what actually happened
but the interesting thing about it is
that and and i like that ridley scott
kind of explored this because this is
absolutely the way it was during this
time period
is that her husband didn't really care
so much that she'd been raped
he cared um that that was i mean even
rape back then was not seen as like an
offense against a woman it was like a
property crime is what it was yeah so i
was like stealing
yeah so he was more worried about his
honor uh about his
former friend like [ __ ] he didn't
really care because honestly when she
you know he was beating the crap out of
her saying you're telling the truth
she's like yes i'm telling you know of
course and then basically he was like oh
well we have to [ __ ] now so that you're
so that he's not the last man that was
with you and she's like yeah i'd kind of
rather not because he's like he's trying
he's like no you have to yeah he was
trying to erase it right and so so like
i said nobody really cared and then well
i was going to say something else but i
can't because it'll spoil the end right
but it's like they nobody really cared
about her
in particular yeah she was just kind of
like and the thing about it was that he
had been gone because he was gone all
the time he was like off doing battles
or stuff because you know that was the
way he made money
and she ran his [ __ ] yeah while he was
gone
and and he wasn't too good at running
the farm yeah and so and she never
really got appreciation for like running
[ __ ] like in his absence successfully
but yeah he also kind of had to see
things from his point of view it was a
pretty barbaric time and the only reason
why
he had that basically that little castle
and all that [ __ ] fiefdom with the
with the uh with the peasants and
everything is because
he was out there kicking ass well yeah
that was the only way that he made money
the only way well that was also the only
way he could survive yeah okay i mean he
was illiterate he wasn't like i said he
wasn't a real good at politicking or
schmoozing if he didn't if he didn't
avenge
her rape through this duel his ass would
have been grass
especially after the [ __ ] even if the
accusation didn't come up
because jacques and the other guys would
have come back for seconds thirds and
fourth and would have constantly punked
him out behind his back and then laughed
about him and then the other knights
would have heard about it and his esteem
would have went down down down and then
nobody'd take him off to war because
he's a cut
those men would [ __ ] gang up on him
and the next thing you know she loses
her home he loses all his land they take
his [ __ ] and replace him with another
[ __ ] knight so there's no choice i
understand the manly dilemma he was in
the other guys with a dog piled up on
him and that would have been the end of
him in the end of her
cheetah yeah it's just it was a bad
situation for everybody involved right
but like i said um
it's interesting because you know her
even her mother-in-law who she super did
not get along with by the way and lived
at their house but she was also kind of
like
the mother-in-law was like look i've
been raped too like just keep your mouth
shut about it um the mother-in-law says
it happened all the time and they didn't
tell the husbands and that's what
jacques says says better not tell your
husband he might kill you
yeah which probably yeah that would
happen yeah
that could happen but she was absolutely
i mean the thing about her character and
it's interesting because like i said you
don't really get much of a sense of her
as a character until the third part of
the movie because well that's why
because the structure is like you know
it's from this guy's point of view and
you know this then the second guy's
point of view and then like from her
point of view so you're seeing you're
seeing her through their eyes they all
basically told the same story they just
characterized the story a little bit
different gave different backgrounds as
to why it happened i mean i really liked
there were like little details it's not
um jacques said she was asking for she
was flirting with him yeah but then
but then they show like what actually
happened later where she's like yeah i
kind of looked at like she was talking
about him and she's like look husband
this is how you have to like pretend to
be nice to people and then she kind of
went and like smiled at him and he's
like oh she digs me you know she's
trying to do courtly politics right
she was trying to like show her husband
how to do it like you have to be
friendly to people and you have to like
you know you have to ask kiss and stuff
like that so she was showing him that
right but adam driver kind of like
perceived it as ooh she digs me
or at least that's a story he told yeah
i think he just liked her and he goes
i'm gonna get that and she's gonna keep
her mouth shut probably because he was
this is like i said this is not a very
legalistic society it's honor bound
society it's like something you'd find
in the middle east today still still
around
[ __ ] she'd have a lot to lose by
[ __ ]
fessing up to the rate because he was
well connected
so he was just trying to weasel his way
into it
into some ass i think yeah i think he
probably thought because he was had the
favor he thought she wasn't going to say
anything he thought she wasn't going to
say anything and he was going to come
back yeah but she was like oh [ __ ] you
i'm absolutely yeah
i [ __ ] i know just what he was saying
and his little line his [ __ ] spiel he
was going to come back repeatedly oh
yeah until he was until he was bored
with her i'm sure he had plans and they
were probably doing that to each other's
wives [ __ ] pretty common back then
and then he would say well she did it
yeah she casts a spell on me
well that [ __ ] like that seems like
that's how he kind of perceives it yeah
yeah look here's another thing and
[ __ ] people who know
medieval history you know between
england and france and germany
those dudes were not good dudes bad
knights and those guys they were they
were gangsters that's all they were they
were just well and they do kind of show
this yeah i mean they do have a few
redeeming qualities but but yeah general
general is a cartel both of the guys are
kind of [ __ ] i mean her husband is not
much better yeah
yeah well
i don't know i think he was a good dude
in terms of he was he was very
conventional for his time yeah he's
trying to follow those rules
and he's not raping other people's wives
unless i think the m his mom brought up
well they go out and rape peasant girls
[ __ ] when they're at war that's what
i'm saying so he was probably raping
women but these weren't noble women they
were just peasant women and he could
right now they didn't count yeah
i mean they counted even less than like
the wealthy women yeah so it's like yeah
they didn't even now you weren't rape
and other nights and normal women's
wives you're all right
yeah they like i said they probably
didn't even consider that a crime right
now because they didn't belong to it
they belonged like i said rape was a
property crime up until
uh quite a quite a long way afterwards
yeah there were no human rights
there were no human rights they were
just human abilities they had the
ability to do this so they did it
yeah and the opportunity to do it so
you know just the way it was
and what's funny is it's just
left to their own devices
society's kind of just evolved in that
direction just human history was mostly
like that
they were just
if you were fearsome you got your way if
you were in a big gang you got your way
and you know the modern nation state is
just an extension of that
not that different
good but the interesting thing about
this movie is that even though it's
essentially showing the same series of
events from three perspectives yeah
there's enough variation in the
perspectives that it actually makes it
really good and like i said there's some
really good like funny little touches in
there
that like when you see things from a
different point of view like like for
example when you see remember that scene
where uh adam driver's character where
he goes in front of the court and he's
like protesting his innocence and he
does that thing with his cape where he's
like swishing it around and and so
you're seeing from his point of view he
was all like fantastic and all this
other [ __ ] but when you see it from
someone else's point of view it looked
kind of lame or like he was like trying
too hard or something like that it was
just like i liked the way that um that
there was just little touches like that
because it's not like the same exact
series of scenes just shown from three
different perspectives it is like kind
of
it there's enough variation in it like i
said because different [ __ ] happened to
different people yeah you know what
enough that you kind of see
i like what cod said man [ __ ] it read
read because it where which one all
three of what he said uh so the question
is did he abuse her i say yes uh yeah
absolutely like i said and and the the
rape from her point of view is like uh
pretty [ __ ] yeah he raped her brittle
he raped her yeah it's then he says what
then what he's a
he said said the movie failed because
the the these manly virtues that go in
the way of the dinosaur the younger
people don't understand them i don't
know well the thing about this movie is
that it's ridley scott i think this
movie costs 100 million dollars to make
they don't really make movies like this
anymore that aren't really aimed toward
like at least in this big budget of a
range oh my god what the [ __ ] is that
somebody said somebody's car alarm is
getting lost
does i didn't even know people had car
alarms that were just sleeping all the
time anymore somebody from another era
turn that [ __ ] off
but um yeah it's like really distracting
so sorry
but the thing about it is that
um
this seems like a movie that you know
it's set in medieval times and it's kind
of like
it's it's geared more toward adults they
don't really make big budget movies like
this like geared toward
an older crowd i guess and i think maybe
that was the problem like ridley scott
he came out and said um the reason that
the movie failed i think it made 30
million and it cost like 100 million
um he said oh it's he was basically like
you know old man yells at cloud where he
was just kind of like oh these
millennials on their [ __ ] phone i'm
like you know millennials are like in
their 30s and 40s and have their own
kids now right but yeah so there's so
sad he just complained about millennials
because that's all they do is learn
stuff on their phone and if it's not on
their phone they don't want to know i
don't really know i do think that this
movie was
geared more toward an older audience um
you know and like i said they don't
really make really big budget movies
like this like geared toward an older
audience also it came out at the same
time as a bunch of other like big movies
and i think so i think maybe if it had
come out like in a different time
because it got like a lot of uh critics
liked it
i didn't like the trailer
maybe that's what it was i didn't think
the promo was good
this this thing you could play this
right alongside
uh the north the north norseman northman
northman you could play it right again
like that uh and excalibur
and conan it'd be it's like that it's
just they're different movies but
they're as good as th they're they're
all as good as each other
and i'm gonna say
i mean this isn't i don't know if i'd
call it necessarily an action movie but
there are like some battle sequences and
uh the duel at the end is actually like
really brutal because like i said the
it's pretty well documented like what
happened so there's a couple battle
scenes you know yeah wars go down but
that's not really what the movie is
about it's mostly it's mostly about
intrigue and characters the adam driver
character is pretty cool the dude that
was the rapist i liked him
yeah i liked him he was just a man of
his time and he was kind of
he was kind of superior to the average
person at that time well he was
definitely superior to the average
person that time he could read and write
latin he was educated and he
he was evidently a good catch all the
girls liked him and uh
the girl who got raped one of her best
friends [ __ ] gave up testimony
against her in court to defend him
because she said she said he likes
she
said
he was handsome and now she's accused
him of rape you know what i mean even
though she knew that she did it but
that's just the medieval mind was not
like that
all right that [ __ ] the middle evil my
girl wouldn't be mine she was trying to
vibe for his attention yeah
even though everybody knew like whatever
everybody knew what he was everybody
knew he was yeah but you know that
i guess even in medieval times those
women like the bad boy you know and even
though he had money and he looked good
and he was educated and he was good at
parties and was [ __ ] had a lot of
charisma and uh those girls liked him
yeah he was charming yeah and in his
defense to his friend you know his
friend was the cat was like
did you do it he was like no no and
there's come on it's important you know
he goes well i love her oh it's okay so
you did it
that's how you did it and he's like well
yeah and he goes we gotta understand
something these people are simple you're
either a villain or a hero you gotta
deny this you gotta deny it a hundred
percent
and then he goes i'll help you out in
the courts yeah
that's basically said he goes
he says i know you for a long time man
you you get all the women they all love
you you don't have to rape them you love
her i know you love her yeah that's
basically what with the council well
like the funny thing we were talking
about this when we were watching the
movie where he decided that he loved her
her name's marguerite yeah he loved her
so therefore so he's like you have to
love me back and i was just like that's
not how that works but okay but yeah
that's kind of like what he assumed
he just he assumed that well you feel
the same way well his feelings are all
that matter
i i think it was a medieval thing where
they they believed in a lot of things
that weren't true they believe yeah
they believe that you couldn't get
pregnant by raping somebody because they
they even said that like they said
several times they said the science
proves
okay besides science proves that a woman
cannot get pregnant by rape because they
do not experience the little death they
don't come yeah so you got a commodore
to get [ __ ] pregnant so they believed
that they didn't know [ __ ] back then
yeah
they were they were still like putting
animals on court
at this time period like they were
accusing animals he was an animal of a
crime yeah like a pig shame on you yeah
you should have known better they did
yeah it's like that's the mentality that
we're dealing with here yeah so
and i think the the mentality basically
she's reminded what i was talking about
i think that they believe that i think
they would probably say some [ __ ] like
well science proves that if i love you
you love me back or i wouldn't be
feeling that yeah it's the love beam
that is love beams it's going back yeah
yeah yeah that sounds like the [ __ ] they
would say yes yeah
that's what they're talking about
but it's just uh
and plus they kind of go into this a
little bit too and during this time
period it was kind of like if you were
kind of a lady you were kind of supposed
to protest so it's like you had to like
push past the protest well well look man
khan says the same thing in mexico in
mexico a lot of shit's still going on
you know they you know in central and
south america they understand honor
based [ __ ] thinking
you know they're fighting each other out
in the streets and shooting each other
and [ __ ] in duels
and it's the same thing in brazilian
brazilian girls growing up
they're catholic
so they have to say no they're throwing
themselves at you saying no
and this is we're gonna okay then you
know they have to in or that's that's
khan can talk about it
he can explain it probably better than i
do it's just part of their ritual
is is is to resist and then you go okay
where are you going and they pull you
right back there's teenagers and [ __ ]
you know
because you know they got the confession
booth
yeah that that fixes everything yeah
the middle east is like that too any
yeah any yeah any any uh so there's
cultural confusions
[ __ ] the north
north america is [ __ ]
kind of a different situation you know
what i mean the uh the the the cultures
and the
the culture is different
what do you call them uh
yeah
the culture is different dj maniac says
i switched over to night shift starting
tonight so now i'll be working sunday to
thursday from 10 pm to 6 30 a.m at least
i have friday and saturday nights free
though oh that's good so you'll always
be able to like come to the side tracks
that's pretty cool oh you've been good
about coming to the once before but yeah
so
i don't know it just it makes me sad
that like this movie wasn't
more successful i guess i can see why
it's not the kind of movie that you
would normally see like a studio paying
100 million dollars for and then
expecting like a bit because it's not a
big superhero movie it's not a big
tentpole movie it's nothing like that
yeah these guys can make a good movie
but they tend to bomb yeah i mean well
like i said they're more geared toward
adults or he has like a very particular
kind of like subject matter that he
likes to make and
a lot of times that's not
usually so i you know maybe his
criticism about millennials or although
like i said millennials are kind of
older now so probably he should be like
talking about younger people than that
but you know yeah younger people
probably aren't going to see a movie
like this because it's kind of like more
of a period drama yeah so you're not
gonna get like a lot of teenagers coming
to see it obviously yeah they wouldn't
they wouldn't be interested in this i
don't think probably not um they
wouldn't wouldn't even be able to relate
to it i don't think
maybe yeah i don't know maybe not it
depends i don't yeah i don't really like
and like you said it's interesting when
you said about the trailer because i was
watching another review of this later
like a guy and he said that when he
first saw the trailer he said man that
looks boring as [ __ ] yeah i did but then
when he actually saw the movie he's like
oh that was really good so you know what
i mean so i don't think i don't think he
got proper promotion
yeah he did and like i said it came out
right around the same time as like a
bunch of other big like movies that
everybody was going to see i think the
movie i think the movie will be
remembered though
yeah i mean it's definitely genre it's
good it's good for this yeah yeah i mean
it's definitely worth watching and it's
i really really liked the structure of
it yeah you know where yeah you get some
of the scenes like repeated but you're
seeing things from like different
perspectives and like the behavior is
slightly different depending on who's
perceiving who so authentic so i thought
that was yeah um a lot of people like
before this came out a lot of people
talked about matt damon's uh mullet yeah
but as far as i could determine that
that's pretty uh period accurate yeah so
it does it looks ridiculous but that's
what their hair looked like back they
had some [ __ ] crazy crazy hair and
they did certain times one of the ones
ahead was the chelsea and it was nothing
but just four locks the rest of the head
they had shaved it was just your bags
and it's because they had
a chain mail leather and chainmail
headdress on top of that so you didn't
want your hair to get caught in your
[ __ ] chain mail so but you wanted to
have hair
so the only hair you could see when they
were wearing that damn helmet and outer
head garment looking thing was just the
front locks
so you had some hair yeah then you took
it off and you you're damn you bald but
then damn you bald yeah
but they walked around like that and it
became kind of like a uh
a sign of being a
badass
probably helped with the lice too i'd
imagine yeah
like not having much hair
the lights had to go into your piano if
that was saxons or franks i don't
remember which ones it was that had that
it might have been saxons
i think saxons had long hair it might
have been norman's
that had the yeah i can't really
remember the chelsea been a long time
since i've taken uh european history you
know what i mean yeah but yeah this is
uh definitely a good flick definitely
worth watching i think it's on disney
plus
uh you know if you want to watch a bill
like i said we bought the blu-ray
because dermot sent us so that so thank
you very much dermot i don't know if
you're here or not but uh yeah this
ended up being uh really good quite
quite good all right so are we it's
almost time for you to check on your on
to food yeah right so we got it we're
cooking some food so we got we gotta let
go check on it all right so we will be
back tomorrow 6 p.m eastern standard
time as usual tomorrow i think we're
going to be talking about uh mad god
because we watched that last night the
phil tippet uh movie so we'll be talking
about that tomorrow so thanks everybody
for dropping by to see us and we will
see you guys again tomorrow